first off I I love this movie I was it's
such a great movie like it's refreshing
to have something I could finally watch
again like with my parents and just like
not have to like Panic about like
anything like oh it's gonna get weird
like or awkward I don't know my parents
have that kind of like sense of humor
though they do so that's good hey the
one thing I have to ask I was just
thinking with the haircut
did they actually shave your hair or was
it uh it was a wig okay we didn't shoot
in sequence so I would have to go from
long hair to short hair yeah so they
felt that that short wig would be the
best way to go which I totally agree
would you cut your hair for real for
real yeah
oh sorry I'm taking over your job no um
I think I would have that haircut did
look good on you okay let's go math in
my videos me and Marlo yeah we go if
there's a sequel and we go to Sicily yes
as Sebastian was just talking about that
as well God I hope enough wouldn't that
be fun Sebastian to go to Italy it would
oh my God first of all the food
a lot of elastic waistbands so I love
I can't get over I love your movie a tag
and I just love all like whenever you
show up in a comedy I'm like always like
thank you thank you it's always great
like seeing you in those I always play
Like A A Wack I do which is kind of fun
in this because she's not
insane yes she's like I usually get
these characters who are like there's
something insane that we have to pull
off something that's Dar weird or
something um especially in tag and
um with Sebastian and uh so I love that
she's kind of the every girl and and
it's a sweet love story and I love
Sebastian so much and I liked being his
partner in crime in this had you met him
before you know yeah he married Us in
tags so I met him that day he was very
quiet on that day of filming and then I
met him at renner's house because we had
like a party there and Renner is a very
good friend of mine
Sebastian said I was very sweet to he
and his wife and like oh come back we're
gonna go here and
um I remember meeting them and being
struck with how you could tell how much
they loved each other and so that was a
very cool thing to sort of bring in to
to have to see that there this
connection they had because I knew that
I had to find that that had to be an
intrinsic and intrinsic thread between
Ellie and and Sebastian in this because
I knew what he and Mana were like in
real life you know so was it ever like
intimidating on set like working with
like De Niro because I know you've both
worked with like big names but like with
you know De Niro if you're right
De Niro
Deer Hunter
Raging Bull yes so why did you do this
movie
because you know uh
first of all the the storyline was
Robert De Niro plays a hairdresser but I
I just wanted the experience of working
with him watching him work being in the
same room it's it's fascinating he's so
open he's so available he's he's funny
and he doesn't take it seriously he has
no ego about it he's the first one to
say well that up yeah excuse me I
screwed that up he's the first one to
say it you know and and I think when
other actors see an actor of that
stature
making mistakes you know you can't
there's there's no place to fail in that
kind of situation and he's always been a
favorite of mine he was a real thrill
and he's a seeker of like the story and
he's all about the work you said curious
earlier that's really a good word for
him and it's just a reminder that
you know people I feel like young kids
are like don't go to acting school as
much anymore and they don't watch old
movies and like the craft of acting and
he's such a person about the craft of
acting so it was like it was really fun
to be around that and the subtlety of
the way he would just change the word
right you think what is that
okay and he opens these little doors
almost for you if you're listening yeah
I remember watching one of those first
days
and he
he called somebody the wrong name he
called like the waitress your name yes
Tigger yeah and in it and he did it
whereas sometimes I'd be like oh I
up the line and he went uh Tigger
what am I what's wrong with me I'm
calling you Hernan and he just played
through and never stop stopped and I was
just a reminder of like why don't you
like he's always searching and seeking
and trusting that whatever is happening
and so it's and encouraging himself yeah
it really is a positive experience
that's one other quick question because
obviously you play her mother in the
movie but if you guys could pick like
any actress or actor living or dead to
play you know your parent one of your
parents in a movie who would it be yeah
Barbara Stanwyck good answer I've always
loved Barbara Stanley such an amazing
actress
spunky and tough and smart and
passionate and emotional and now she was
great I would love for her to I don't
know if she'd be a very warm and cuddly
mom no but she would be great to play
with
um I was really grateful that Jim
I got to have this experience so I don't
even want to dance on like having there
being anybody better than Kim because I
love this and it was like
you know she's iconic and then you meet
her and she's everything and a bag of
nuts like she's like warm and generous
and funny and kind and so easy to work
with so you're just like oh this is
heaven because you never know no but
it's true I don't know because I'm
wearing pancakes
oh my God is a blush and bashful
um no but I maybe Jessica Lange I love
Jessica Lange so maybe that but we'll
see but it doesn't get better than this
one thank you for your time I love
talking to fellow blondes as well so
mine's not real